what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into technically
this is an epilogue for flash war but if
anything I'd say this is probably the
beginning of heroes and crisis because
it goes directly into it like Wally
West's story from here follows directly
into heroes in crisis which is actually
a really cool idea and I'm pretty
excited to see where Tom King takes he's
been dropping hints and we'll talk about
an interview he did with comic book
resources here a little bit but what
this initially does is this picks up
with iris West as she's basically just
sort of writing about things that are
going on and it's kind of funny because
remember iris has kind of been lost in
the shuffle and the reason why is
because one of the things that we had
learned in DC Universe rebirth number
one was it 10 years of memories 10 years
of life had basically been ripped out of
people's minds they'd lost the last ten
years of the life they lived and what it
did is it allowed DC to basically go
through and start bridging the gap right
to say hey so people didn't really seem
to like the new 52 when it came to the
long run so we're gonna get rid of all
the things that people hate it we're
gonna keep the things they loved and
we're just gonna blend the new 52 and
the pre new 52 era together if you don't
know what that means all it means is IDC
is gonna act like they never rebooted
that's really what it's basically coming
down to and so for for characters like
Wally West who came back it basically
meant that hey there were a few things
he remembered but there are also a lot
of things that he forgot and for
characters like iris West admit the
exact same thing and it wasn't until
recently that iris began to realize that
there were a lot of things if she didn't
remember your memories that have been
taken away now some of those are coming
back to remember a lot of those are
still gone and we still don't really
have an answer to that these are little
things that they kind of get tied into
this and one of the things that iris
does is she goes through and you're
really goes through and starts talking
about Wally now this is kind of
interesting here because what's
happening in this this story that's
basically being written here at least
being done by Joshua Williamson is this
basically his way of going back and
altering the origin of Wally West maybe
not really altering it so much as sort
of well I guess yeah he's really
altering it here or at least from the
Mark Waid version anyway now this is
gonna kind of be met with mixed reviews
to be honest I mean if I'm being honest
with you guys I don't think it's that
big of a deal
because I don't think most people care
about the origin of Wally West they care
about the things that Wally West did
when he was the flash and so if if
Joshua Williams didn't come back and
said like well actually Wally was never
faster than Barry Allen then that would
piss off wally west fans because like
the one thing they have that
differentiates Wally from Barry the fact
that Wally mainlines the Speed Force
he's faster than
Barry Allen different things like that
but for the most part actually I think
the way that Joshua Williamson does is
origin here is better than the marker
the verse that Mark Waid did now when
iris West does this she kind of like
reflects on the idea of Wally right you
know like I remember him when he was a
little baby different things like that
now when Mark Waid took over the flash
store a little bit of history when well
really after Barry Allen died in crisis
on Infinite Earths the title was handed
over to Mike Barron and Mike Barron
basically wrote Wally as hey he's a guy
living in Barry shadow and just kind of
continuing on from crisis on Infinite
Earths so Wally was one of the few
people who actually remember the events
of crisis on Infinite Earths and that's
why I kind of works is because in DC
rebirth theories one of the few people
I'm sorry Wally comes back and he's one
of the few people who remembers the
events of Flashpoint which caused this
whole new universe and memories being
lost and the intervention of document
hatton and so on which he wakes Barry up
to and so in this whole situation when
really when Mike Barron essentially left
you had a couple of fill-in writers and
then with issue number 62 Mark Waid took
over and the first thing he wrote
between issue 62 to 65 was a story
called Born to Run which was the new
origin of Wally West after the events of
crisis on Infinite Earths so it was
written in 92 something along those
lines and it was totally different from
the origin you're seeing here because
what we ended up finding out is that is
that really in terms of Wally's parents
they really had no business being
parents and the result was that after
about a decade or so he was brought over
to iris West he moved in with her she
you know he eventually met Barry Allen
the flash and of course he was doused
with chemicals in the same way Barry
Allen was and went on to become Kid
Flash what this does is it modifies it
just a hair and it's genius the way it
does because what it what does what
happens is it creates this extremely
strong bond between iris and and Wally
instead of it being as though iris is
like hey you can come crash with me for
the summer it's one of these things
where iris had basically raised Wally
ever since he was a baby and the reason
why is because Wally's parents were
basically negligent they were asleep
behind the wheel they argued they fought
they had no business being parents but
instead of Wally being handed over to
Iris when he was a lot older what ended
up happening is he was handed over to
Iris as a baby she basically took him
took him up for adoption and she'd live
with him ever since well actually now
that I think about it he doesn't really
change anything I think he provides more
of a back end yeah because what it base
what it says here is that ya like Wally
came to live with with her when she was
older okay so that Mark Waid origin is
still intact okay my bad my mistake
the Mark Waid origin is still intact but
he adds a little bit to the background
of it
I mean that's that's so kind of cool I
would kind of prefer the idea that Wally
had lived with her his whole life uh but
then again that wouldn't really explain
why Barry had never seen Wally before
but in fact range you know with with
this bit what is up happening is of
course as the Mark Waid origin had
progressed and even as the original Kid
Flash origin before crisis on Infinite
Earths had progressed Wally met Barry
when he was younger and this ultimately
led to the experiment that led to Wally
getting his powers now this is why
things are so cool because it all comes
from the perspective of iris West
so with Wally gaining the powers of the
flash and becoming Kid Flash in the eyes
of Wally he looked up to Barry as a hero
but in reality Wally was rapidly
becoming the new flash it was only ever
a matter of time and he was an
inspiration to a lot of different people
when Barry died and he went on to become
the new flash in the early days again
under Mike Barron Wally was living under
the shadow of Barry but once he broke
out then he became everybody else's here
and he inspired other people to become
heroes that's one of the important
things to bear in mind here and it's
really kind of a way for Joshua
Williamson to create this is a sort of
love letter to Wally West fans and so
it's very important for a lot of flash
fans because that's really how Joshua
Williamson writes this that the way iris
is writing the story is the way Wally
West fans see the character of Wally
West that I've watched him grow as a
character and he really really really
needs to come back so it's it's the cool
thing and it's a really cool moment the
issue with this is that for Wally
himself he's on the hunt for his kids
and he's just running around the earth
as fast as he possibly can now in
reality I would say there's a little bit
of influence here from like Kingdom Come
just a smidge but a little bit of
influence here from Kingdom Come those
you guys don't know Kingdom Come was a
story which largely dealt with all the
Golden Age superheroes except for Wally
West because he was the most popular
flash in the only real flash at the time
and so when Kingdom Come was written up
because it was written by Mark Waid
basically uh he took Wally West from you
know and and just kind of threw him over
in and said well he's part of the Golden
Age team which doesn't really make any
sense one of the things that it happened
is that after everything had popped off
with with you know with the death of the
Joker and so on and so forth that Wally
had basically just spent all of his time
running around Central City just at an
astronomical rate just running around so
fast all the time maybe was Keystone
City
whichever one it was he was running
around all the time super fast and this
is kind of a hint to that in the sense
that he's basically running around the
entire earth trying to find his kids now
it's kind of interesting here because in
reality we know he'll never find them if
we were to look beyond the pages a bit
and sort of jump into the mind of Wally
West we could say Wally knows he'll
never find them but he knows you
finest kids but it's one of these things
like it gives him the feeling of
actually being like moving in a forward
direction it's like a movie plot right
like when you're watching a movie one of
the film tactics is to have the actors
walking because walking around gives the
illusion that the story is moving
forward and so for the character of
Wally West it's the same thing it gives
him the feeling that he's actually doing
something and so the result here is that
we kind of switch over to Barry and it's
one of these things where Barry's been
really has been talking to Iris and the
whole thing that iris takes you to where
Barry wants to take a hand wants to jump
in and wants to say hey look we have to
go find him ultimately irises responses
you have to let him run but you have to
let him work this out he has to come to
terms with this on his own if you go to
Wally and if you go to him and you say
Wally you have to stop then he's going
to say that if he never finds his kids
you're the reason why you stopped him
from finding them whereas he has to go
through this and realize he can't find
them doing it on his own it's the only
real way for him to accept the truth of
the situation the other half of this is
that for the character of new 52 Wally
West the younger Wally West in reality
it was DC's attempt to rework in and to
create a new version of the character
under estimating the popularity of the
classic red-haired Wally West and so the
result is that when the original Wally
came back
the new version of Wally never really
had a place in the flash comics it was
it was one of those things where he was
sort of he wasn't necessarily out but he
was certainly being handed his hat and
at this point now they're kind of
shuffling him out and they're basically
throwing it like they're really kind of
moving up to the Teen Titans that really
seems to be the case and it kind of
makes sense to a degree and all honesty
I love the idea of like a younger fresh
vibrant version version of Wally who
came from like a wholly different
lifestyle I would kind of like to see
him stay around but the decision that
DC's making is to push me over to Teen
Titans and to sort of make room here for
for a new Wally or at least best seems
to be the indication and the reason why
is because there's a sort of blow-up the
sort of argument that takes place
between the new version of Wally and and
Barry Allen and the younger Wally
basically says look before the events of
Flashpoint when I was in the 25th
century I saw what the entire DC history
was before the events of Flashpoint
and before the events of Flashpoint I
didn't exist I was a nonentity there was
no such thing as me it's because of what
you did that I now exist you change time
you changed history you changed
everything you basically created a whole
new universe and I'm here now and in
reality this is a this was really a way
for Williamson to sort of find an option
to bring new 52 Wally back and the
reason why is because what the new
version of Wally doesn't know and what
Barry Allen doesn't know
most everybody doesn't know is that it's
really dr. Manhattan who's responsible
for all this and so the beauty of this
move is that it makes it possible for
the huge revelation to come out for the
new version of wall-e to find out what's
actually happened that things were
supposed to go back to normal but dr.
Mann hadn't intervened screwed
everything out took everything away
shuffle things around and the result is
that the entire DC landscape is in his
current state and so it would allow him
to bring new 52 wall-e back to back to
the to the flash comics now in reality
it's a smart move I mean it while I
might disagree with it it's a smart move
by Williamson and the reason why is
because this new version of wall-e has
gotten a lot of character development
you know he's really kind I mean until
we start getting into stories where he
starts aging up where he starts getting
older that really isn't a really isn't a
whole lot you can do with him so forth
once all this is done like once this
whole mythos is set in stone with
regards to the flash and everything you
know the the quote-unquote project is
complete with regards to rebirth then
what you would see is you would see the
flash comic consisting of all the
speedsters Impulse giant iris West
probably Jay Garrick and I wouldn't be
surprised if they start breaking it off
into new flash books but I wouldn't be
surprised if you see things sort of
branch out and sort of split off and it
makes perfect sense so again with with
this conversation kind of continuing on
it's one of these things where we're
Irish offers again a little more input
here and basically saying that when it
comes to the character of Barry the one
of the big things that Barry always
focused on was the idea that hope was
the driving force behind it it was it
was the hope that he could do good the
hope that he could save lives where he
lost his mom and different things like
that but for Wally it was more of being
a traditional superhero and trying to
live up to Barry Allen's legacy and then
improve on the legacy of Barry Allen and
so when you combine these two things
together where you have very sort of
running around and being the flash doing
what the flash does ultimately what iris
says is that Barry's biggest problem is
that he never really took time to fix
himself that he never really took time
to focus on himself very always focused
on everybody else and he wouldn't really
come out and talk about the kind of
things that bothered him and so that's
what she that's one is up happening like
Barry's been trying to find Wally been
chasing after Wally he can't find him
and so when he finally goes to Irish he
says sit down like just stop running
you're not gonna catch him stop chasing
after him stop being the hero of Wally
West Wally West has to do his own thing
he has to be is you have to let him
stand on his own two feet he has to come
to grips of this on his own term until
that happens you're gonna have to do the
hardest thing for any flash to do which
is to just stay put and so ultimately if
Walli ends up coming back and when he
does he basically says I can't find my
kids
they don't exist or or something but
there's no way for me to find and I
remember they're basically shut off to
time travel they can't access Hypertime
they can't travel back and forth through
time and that's what makes things so
complicated is that when it comes to the
timestream I mean it's a vast ocean and
so what what essentially is going on is
it IRA and Jai Wes or iris Ajay West
it's like basically taking a pebble and
throwing it into the Pacific Ocean and
then saying now go find it it's
impossible I mean it's just as
insurmountable feat because they could
be anywhere in the timestream at any
point in time
wally west would have to jump into every
single second of every single time every
single point in time in order to locate
them and even then there's no guarantee
it's entirely possible he could jump
back to last Thursday at 5:30 1 p.m. and
10 seconds and they are at 5:31 p.m. and
11 seconds they're a fraction of a
second ahead of him it's impossible
it breaks down to tiny different
fragments I mean minuscule moments so
small that when you're when you're a
flash you know almost nobody else
realizes those moments have passed so
it's it's you know if they're the time
stream out there somewhere it's
impossible to find them they would have
to come to him it's the only conceivable
way to locate them and so because of the
fact this is taken such a huge emotional
toll on Wally West wonders of happening
is Superman and Wonder Woman are
contacted to take him to a place called
sanctuary now this is when we start to
get into this interview with Tom kink
right now
sanctuary is an idea that has not been
explored we don't know what sanctuary is
outside of Tom Kings interview with
Kelly Book Resources where he said the
sanctuary is basically a place for like
heroes in crisis it's like a Veterans
Crisis place it's a place that heroes go
when they even do it a trauma so extreme
that they basically have to talk it out
because it could crush them now in
reality this makes perfect sense and
it's a way for DC to make their
characters even more grounded intangible
because you here by that all the time
right like a soldier comes back from
Iraq Afghanistan or even during the
Vietnam War especially that War World
War tear what were one things like that
and they come back with an altered mind
state PTSD any number of things but they
don't see the world the way they used to
because of the things they saw in that
conflict and they have to talk it out
some recover some don't but when you're
a superhero and you're constantly
running around saving other people's
lives and you're constantly running
around you know fighting bad guys it
takes an emotional toll on a person and
it makes sense that if the heroes are
gonna be more grounded and more tangible
that you can't have them running around
being heroes all the time and then take
the idea of this these traumatic
Frances and sweep them under the rug as
if they're not there eventually a hero
would snap and that's why this is so
cool because it introduces the concept
of what happens if a hero breaks what
happens if Barry Allen and doers of
trauma so extreme it's more than he can
handle
and he just cracks what will that he was
like what were those set of events look
like and what do you do with you what do
you do in that situation
and so it's beautifully done because
with him basically being whisked off to
sanctuary this leads to heroes in crisis
and it leads to like that whole idea of
what Tom King is working on now again we
don't really know what it's gonna be we
don't know if it's just gonna be a whole
bunch of heroes sitting in a room in a
circular fashion talking about all the
traumatic experiences or if it's going
to be like we're trying to keep heroes
from breaking and we're gonna see like
the return of heroes different things
like that we have no idea the
possibilities are endless here so it can
go in almost any conceivable direction
but it's pretty it's pretty funny it's
pretty cool here because Wally said I'm
sorry Barry sits down and talks to
Batman and he says hey man like I feel
like this is this has something to do
with what we did you know this this has
something to do with the fact that that
we found the button that we figured out
what was going on there were at least we
have an idea what was going on we chased
down this ultimate power that was
responsible for perfect for adjusting
everything but we haven't told everybody
yet because remember Batman in Barry
Allen are the only ones who know they're
the only ones who know that eobard
thawne was presumably disintegrated of
course he returned later on were the
only ones who know that he claimed to
have seen God with you know they're the
only ones who know that that have
actually like visited the flashpoint
universe even after the flashpoint
universe was supposed to have been
destroyed and they're the only ones who
know that some ultimate being out there
has basically been responsible for
everything well them in Superman because
Superman was told about that by both
jor-el his father and Mixel pedelec so
we know that like those kinds of things
are happening but for the most part the
larger superhero team doesn't know and
it's a huge amount of guilt like it's a
huge amount of responsibility to have on
your shoulders and so like like when
you're walking around with all that
stuff it's just kind of like but if we
just came clean to everybody then like
everything would be great but the funny
thing about this is that is not so you
know not in so many words kind of
reading between the lines Batman's whole
idea is but we don't know enough though
what do we tell them we found this
button in the Abarth on died and I saw
my dad like where do you go from there's
no information to give anybody as it was
kind of a cool thing it's because all
this that everything that's happened so
far in rebirth is all feeding back in on
these heroes and is taking a huge toll
and the whole point of sanctuary is to
give them a place to sort of get past
that so I'm really excited to see what
happens like I'm really excited to see
where this goes from here without being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to
commerce explain make sure you guys
sub button to become part of the Robin
Corps if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]